und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend es ist der tag nach dem sturm der
tag nach dem für alle welt sichtbar
wurde
wozu populismus fähig ist insbesondere
wenn er im zentrum der macht angelangt
ist
wie leicht es demagogen feld radikale zu
erwecken und andere überhaupt erst zu
radikalisieren
die junge frau den gestern starb als sie
durchs kapital stürmte war ein glühender
trump in einem personenkult erlegen den
sie mit dem leben bezahlt die
institutionen haben sich zwar gegen die
angriffe gewehrt so beiden wurde später
trotzdem noch offiziell zum präsidenten
gekürt und einige hochrangige
republikaner rückten von donald trump
öffentlich ab aber der schaden der
angerichtet wurde ist unübersehbar
nicht nur an verwüsteten büros und
verstörten parlamentarier ihn ist es
fast den tag in washington zusammen
abgeordnete und senatoren in gasmasken
auf der flucht vor dem mob im symbol der
amerikanischen demokratie dem us capitol
dieser abgeordnete steht seiner kollegin
bei sie berichten am tag danach
wir saßen in der falle es waren so 15 20
minuten wo wir umringt waren und es
keinen weg raus gab es war völliges
durcheinander und chaos ich habe so was
noch nie erlebt es gibt mir großes
mitgefühl für alle opfer von terror
situationen
es dauerte bis die ausgangssperre griff
und das kapitol geräumt war
eskortiert von nationalgardisten kehren
die kongressmitglieder zurück in den
sitzungssaal
erschüttert sind sie politiker beider
seiten sehen eine mitschuld bei
präsident trump dieser tag hinterlässt
einen schandfleck auf unserem land der
nicht leicht auszuradieren sein wird es
ist das endgültige schreckliche
vermächtnis des 45 präsidenten er war
ohne zweifel unser schlimmster wir haben
einen aufstand erlebt angezettelt von
dem präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
dennoch legten auch nach dem sturm aufs
kapital samt getreue kongressmitglieder
erneut einspruch gegen das wahlergebnis
ein
mit starren blick auf trumps an
und eigene wahlchancen die möglichkeit
beanstandungen zu hören ist doch
entscheidend und dies ist der ort wo die
einwände gehört debattiert und endgültig
gelöst werden sollten die blockierer
niedergestimmt am frühen morgen wurde
joe biden formell als sieger ausgerufen
joseph biden aus delaware hat 306
stimmen bekommen derweil sperrt twitter
trump übergangsweise facebook bis auf
weiteres so dass er seine lügen vom
wahlbetrug nicht mehr verbreiten kann
stattdessen lässt er über seinen
sprecher twittern obwohl ich dem ausgang
der wahl überhaupt nicht zustimmen kann
und die fakten für mich sprechen
wird es denn auch am 20 januar eine
ordentliche amtsübergabe geben
gestern hatte trump in einer
aufrührerischen rede seine anhänger noch
angefeuert auf das kapitol zu
marschieren heute kursieren bilder wie
er sich mit seiner familie zuvor in
stimmung gebracht hat erste rufe werden
laut ihn nach dem 25 verfassungszusatz
des amtes zu entheben rufe auch von
republikanern
der präsident hat sich losgesagt von
seinen pflichten und der realität
deswegen fordere ich den
vize-präsidenten und das kabinett auf
dafür zu sorgen dass die nächsten wochen
für das amerikanische volk sicher sind
laut der new york times sollen die
bilder des aufstands trump freude
bereitet haben es sind noch 13 tage bis
zur amtsübergabe ja und seine motive
sind hat das alles gestern live vom
kapitol beobachtet und miterlebt
jedenfalls bis zu dem zeitpunkt an dem
er und sein team selbst attackiert
wurden eine der großen fragen die sie in
diesem tag stellt ist warum das capitol
an einem so sensiblen tag mit
angekündigte großdemonstration wütender
wahlverlierer nicht besser geschützt
wurde also man kann sich das auch noch
mal ansehen zum vergleich wie massiv das
aufgebot der nationalgarde in washington
war während der black live matters demos
im juli das sieht man hier auf dem foto
und der unterschied zu gestern der der
körper wirklich größer nicht sein wie
wird das jetzt in den usa diskutiert
ja das wird heftig diskutiert weil man
der capital police die eigentlich
zuständig ist versagen vorwirft es ist
in der tat rätselhaft denn man wusste
vorher 30.000 demonstranten kommen alle
strump anhänger darunter auch viele
milizionäre es waren am vorabend waffen
sichergestellt worden mehrere personen
festgenommen worden
also das aufgebot das wir dort gesehen
haben ich sag mal einige dutzend
polizeibeamte lächerlich im vergleich zu
den 2000 die eigentlich die cap de
police aufbieten könnte nationalgarde
hätte man dazu rufen können man wagt gar
nicht sich auszudenken was noch hätte
passieren können denn die capital police
hat tatsächlich zwei rohrbomben gestern
auch gefunden die waren ganz offenbar
zündfähig sie wurden entschärft wenn die
einer mit ins kapitol genommen hätte
hätte es noch viel schlimmer ausgehen
gehen können also die kerb populismus
einige fragen beantworten in den
nächsten wochen in der tat
außerdem gibt es jetzt das haben wir
eben ja auch ein bericht gehört eine
diskussion ob man nicht noch kurzfristig
in irgendeiner form des amtes enthebt
womöglich über diesen zusatz artikeln
der verfassung wie ernst ist das
zunehmen wird es das wird das
tatsächlich überlegt also es wurde
offenbar im weißen haus gestern
diskutiert weil auch mitarbeiter den
eindruck hatten dass donald trump
regelrecht einem wahn verfallen ist aber
ehrlicherweise ist das auch nicht ganz
einfach dieses absetzen nachdem
fünfundzwanzigster verfassungszusatz
vizepräsident pence müsste mit
mindestens der hälfte des kabinetts
gemeinsam einen brief schreiben das der
präsident abgesetzt ist dieser brief an
den kongress in dem moment wäre pence
tatsächlich dann präsident aber donald
trump könnte einspruch einlegen
ebenfalls per brief in dem moment wäre
er wieder präsident und dann müsste
vizepräsident pence das gesamte kabinett
hinter sich bringen um den präsidenten
abzusetzen und am ende müsste der
kongress über diesen disput entscheiden
in dem moment wäre pence tatsächlich
weiter präsident aber wenn die
entscheidung vor der amtseinführung von
joe biden fällt dann könnte doch wieder
präsident werden also es wird glaube ich
nicht viel bringen in den 13 tagen
und man macht sich sorgen was in diesen
13 tagen noch geschehen könnte
eben nicht nur diesen bereits zehn tagen
sondern damit trampeltier mutmasslich
nicht aufhören also auch danach nicht
ja davon ist auszugehen also donald
trump ist ja nicht weg nachdem er aus
dem amt
im grunde genommen gegangen ist sondern
er wird weiterhin eine ganz ganz
wichtige rolle spielen ich sag mal beim
trump ismus die republikanische partei
wird sich entscheiden müssen ist sie
eine drastische partei spaltet sie sich
möglicherweise das deutet sich an
einigen stellen an
aber die tram pisten so nenne ich sie
mal sitzen ja schon im kongress hier in
washington
und donald trump wird eben das was er
bisher hinter sich hat nämlich die macht
über wahrscheinlich millionen von
anhängern in den usa auch in den
nächsten vier jahren nutzen und wird
alles tun um die politik von joe biden
zu sabotieren
warum sprechen wir im laufe der
sendungen noch mit einem us
republikanern dank erstmal elmar bis
hierhin schon am 19
dezember als tramp noch twittern konto
derzeit ist sein account gesperrt rief
er seine anhänger explizit dazu auf am
sechsten januar nach washington zu
kommen zu einem großen protest der wie
es schrieb wild werde und wie wild es
gestern tatsächlich zuging haben ganz
besonders eindrücklich kollegen des
britischen fernsehsenders itv
eingefangen
sie waren mit kamera tatsächlich mitten
im geschehen
eine für das team selbst gefährliche
reporter leistung der wir aber ein
zeithistorisches dokument verdanken vor
allem über das was sich innerhalb des
kapitols abspielt der mob ist durch ihm
folgt ein reporterteam des britischen
senders itv
innenansicht des irrsinns und die frage
nach dem warum
gibt es tiere firma stars wie den usa
wenn er nur bei assassins wenn ihr geist
des tors von triberg wir protestieren
das ist kein protest
das ist ein sturm sie wollen dass es
knallt man hat es ihnen in den kopf
gesetzt
macht kaputt was euch kaputt macht
entdeckung das volk kommt
bis zur tür nur gottlob bilder die
bizarre kaum sein können
die wut bricht sich bahn entlädt sich
etwa am namensschild von nancy pelosi
der verhassten vorsitzenden des
repräsentantenhauses das team mittendrin
[Musik]
die polizei in der unterzahl und für
einen kurzen moment haben die
randalierer das gefühl von macht
betreten verboten gilt nicht mehr
wehrlos schreibtisch alles offen alles
einsehbar triumph ein albtraum der
irgendwann endet und doch nicht enden
soll
solange er dem hilft der die geister
rief und aus berlin ist sonst der
bundesaußenminister zugeschaltet heiko
maas guten abend herr maas hajo funke
als sie das gestern dann gehört gesehen
erfahren haben was ich da in washington
abspielt wie wurde das von ihnen auch
mit mitarbeitern im auswärtigen amt
bewertet als der versuch eines
staatsstreiches immerhin war der
anhänger eines noch-amtsinhaber sie
daraus kapital zu stürmen ich saß im
flieger auf dem rückflug von jordanien
nach berlin zusammen mit vielen
kolleginnen kollegen aus dem auswärtigen
amt einige von denen die auch vorher
schon in washington dies getan habe und
natürlich haben wir das per live ticker
oder livestream verfolgt und ich muss
sagen ich habe selten
so viel stille in unserem flugzeug
gehört wie in diesen momenten weil die
kolleginnen und kollegen vor allen
dingen die die washington kennen und
auch viele bekannte da haben einfach
geschockt und sprachlos gewesen sind
dennoch ich glaube die richtige antwort
hat der kongress gegeben nachdem das
kapital dort überfallen worden ist in
dem alle entscheidungen getroffen worden
sind die die voraussetzungen schaffen
dass joe biden am 20 januar jetzt auch
als präsident vereidigt werden kann und
den mann im weißen haus jetzt auch
endlich erklärt hat dass er zu einer
friedlichen amtsübergabe bereit ist das
ist ganz wichtig um zu zeigen dass
diejenigen die das capitol gestürmt
haben am schluss nicht gewonnen haben ja
der mann im weißen haus wie sie sagten
hat aber seine wahlniederlage immer noch
nicht anerkannt wird weiter für unruhe
sorgen ist anzunehmen dass muss auch die
europäischen regierungen beunruhigen
wenn man sie fragt sich natürlich wie
ist joe biden und und der
vize-präsidentin harris gelingen kann
dieses große wichtige land ruhe zu
bringen in den nächsten jahren ich
glaube er wird seine wahlniederlage nie
anerkennen das ganze hat ja system wird
damit die voraussetzungen dafür schaffen
dass er immer behaupten kann er sei
eigentlich noch der rechtmäßige
präsident und ihm sei die wahl gestohlen
worden
insofern muss man damit rechnen dass er
zwar aus dem weißen haus verschwindet
aber nicht aus der amerikanischen
öffentlichkeit das heißt er wird von der
seitenlinie aus versuchen politik weiter
mit zu bestimmen
wenn man sieht wie viele menschen er
mobilisiert und wie er sie auf herzen
kann dann ist das sicherlich bedenklich
und deshalb wird das eine aufgabe für
joe biden und kämmerer harris die
wahrscheinlich größer ist als die je ein
vorgänger zu bewältigen hatte dieses
völlig dieses völlig polarisierte land
wieder zusammenzuführen und das wird die
voraussetzung dafür sein dass er
vernünftig politik betreiben können im
übrigen nicht nur im inland sondern auch
im ausland
dieses polarisierte land das sie
beschreiben dass das ist ja nicht nur
ein rein amerikanisches phänomen wir
haben solche phänomene auch hier in
europa werden auch eine art versuchten
sturm auf den reichstag auch bei weitem
nicht vergleichbar mit dem was sich in
washington abgespielt hat aber das
phänomen als solches findet ja auch hier
statt vor allem dieser glaube auch an
verschwörungs minuten
ja das ist so das ist überall auch die
gleiche grundmelodie und im übrigen ist
es ja nichts was gestern entstanden ist
und auch nicht nur die rede von jump
bevor die ins kapitol gezogen sind war
ausschlaggebend sondern das was er vier
jahre davor gemacht hat das land zu
polarisieren hass und hetze zu
verbreiten auf die art und weise auch
politisch zu mobilisieren und das kennen
wir auch in europa und deshalb sollte
uns das allen eine lehre sein und
diejenigen die sich als demokratinnen
und demokraten fühlen und die nicht
wollen dass wir in einer gesellschaft
leben in der hass und hetze den ton
angibt wir müssen etwas dagegen tun das
ist im übrigen nicht nur eine aufgabe
für minister oder für abgeordnete
politiker das ist eine aufgabe für jeden
demokraten und jede demokratie und es
beginnt zu hause auf dem arbeitsplatz wo
auch immer den mund aufzumachen wenn man
sieht dass diejenigen die mit hass und
hetze und mit verschwörungstheorien
versuchen den lauf der dinge zu
verändern und menschen zu verführen
da muss man einfach gegenhalten wer sich
auf jeden fall wohl über diese
ereignisse gestern vermutlich eher
gefreut hat ist dann der mann
entwicklung und der mann in moskau
es gab ja auch schon entsprechende
reaktionen also der sprecherin des
russischen außenministeriums hat das
wahlsystem der usa als alis bezeichnet
das nicht mehr heutigen standards
entspreche und in china wird der mob in
washington mit den protesten der
demokratiebewegung in hongkong
verglichen und man weist auch noch
darauf hin wie schön es doch ist dass
man selbst keinen bisher erschossen
hätte anders als in städten wie geht die
europäische wie geht die deutsche
außenpolitik damit um
na ja das ist wirklich schmerzhaft wenn
man das wird was in peking moskau auch
in minsk oder in teheran dazu verbreitet
worden ist und deshalb ist es ja so
wichtig gewesen dass die demokratischen
institutionen in den usa in washington
schnell gehandelt haben dass joe biden
jetzt vereidigt wird am 20 januar und
dass er das was er angekündigt hat
nämlich die vereinigten staaten wieder
zu einem verantwortungsvollen player auf
der internationalen bühne zu machen dass
er das umsetzt
und da hat er sicherlich nicht nur
unsere unterstützung in deutschland
sondern auch in ganz europa denn wir
hatten in den letzten vier jahren in
washington einen präsidenten der
behauptet hat dass die größten feinde
der usa russland china und europa sind
gehört jetzt hoffentlich alles der
vergangenheit an und das ist die
grundlage für eine bessere
internationale zusammenarbeit für die
lösung von kriegen und konflikten die
wir schon viel zu lange mit uns
herumschleppen
und das ist die beste antwort auf das
was wir aus moskau peking oder teheran
gehört haben es könnte aber auch nicht
von king seien ja so wunschdenken denn
joe biden wird sehr damit beschäftigt
sein mit innenpolitik und diesen laden
irgendwie wieder zusammenzuführen
glauben sie wirklich dass die usa an den
nächsten jahren die kraft haben wieder
eine eine führungsmacht zu sein ist ein
großes vakuum das dass donald trump auch
hinterlassen das ist ganz sicherlich so
und es gibt auch keine gewissheit dass
diese schwierige aufgabe dies
innenpolitisch gibt in den usa
gemeistert wird oder das ist
möglicherweise etwas dauern wird
trotzdem bin ich fest davon überzeugt
das ist all das was wir wissen und hören
aus washington dass joe biden die
vereinigten staaten wieder zurückführen
will auf die internationale bühne und
zwar nicht mit prinzipien aller america
first sondern der weiß dass der
klimawandel die digitalisierung die
pandemie dass wir dafür internationale
antworten brauchen und ich glaube das
ist auch all das was wir alle erwarten
und wofür wir die vereinigten staaten
bitter brauchen
das ist in den letzten ferien fast ein
komplettausfall gewesen den wir da
erlebt haben und das ist die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir in der
internationalen zusammenarbeit deutlich
weiter kommen als es in der letzten zeit
der fall gewesen ist sagte außenminister
herr maas danke für das gespräch
es lohnt sich die anhänger die der
gestern auf die demokratischen
institutionen der usa los gingen noch
einmal näher zu betrachten
anhänger zu denen jump in seiner
videobotschaft sagte er liebe sie und
sie seien besondere leute seine tochter
ivanka sprach sie in einem tweet als
amerikanische patrioten an
da waren bereits neonazis im capitol auf
deren sweat shirts das wort bürgerkrieg
gedruckt war und camp auschwitz anna
maria schoo er war einer der anführer
des mobs von gestern und sorgte mit
seinem bizarren auftritt für das bild
des tages
angeli trompeter und rechtsextremer
verschwörungs gläubiger donald trump ist
sein präsident juan on seine religion
letztendlich ist es bei kindern so dass
man es nicht mehr mit einer gewissen
verschwörungs erzählung zu tun hat
sondern mit einem ganzen netzwerk es
geht aber schon gegen die demokraten es
ist pro tram trump wird auch ganz oft
als eine art heiland tatsächlich
dargestellt also es gibt diverse teams
dem beispielsweise mit engelsflügeln
zeigen und als erlöser sehen der gegen
eine scheinbare ja gruppe mächtige
gruppe kämpft die kinder entführt oder
andere dinge plant um die gesellschaft
zu zerstören verschwörungs gläubiger wie
angie die rechtsextreme wie die porträts
antisemiten mit camp auschwitz pullover
sie alle mischten sich unter die
demonstranten und fühlten sich
angefeuert von ihrem präsidenten
wir werden niemals aufgeben
es passiert einfach nicht man gibt nicht
klein bei wenn es um diebstahl geht
unser land hat genug
wir werden das nicht länger hinnehmen
darum geht's hier salonfähig macht und
zwar nicht in der politischen nischen
ecke sondern als präsident einer großen
demokratie in online foren wie diesen
hatten sich offenbar viele demonstranten
im vorfeld verabredet in einem chat zum
sturm auf das kapitol gerufen und an
fahrkarten geteilt es wirkt wie eine
lange geplante aktion
und eine die nach dem willen vieler
anhänger erst der anfang sein soll
dan coats ist uns aus washington
zugeschaltet eine lange karriere in der
republikanischen partei war botschafter
in deutschland nach nine eleven
er war dann unter donald trump
nationaler geheimdienst koordinator die
nato also der chefaufseher der
amerikanischen geheimdienste ein posten
den er dann aber letzten sommer im
august auf gehabt evening dan coats
schön genannt wie sehr haben die
ereignisse gestern sie beängstigt oder
auch geschmerzt erinnerte mich
persönlich ein nein als wir an im
fernsehen verfilmt wie wir angeklopft
wir müssen zusehen wie unsere demokratie
von gegnern angegriffen bruder von
ausländischen gegnern brasilien
passierte am zweiten tag als botschafter
in deutschland das war ein schock für
uns und ein schock für die ganze welt
gestern abend gestern nachmittag was
hier bei uns in den usa gab es wieder
einen solchen schock wir sahen den
fernsehbildschirm und konnten nicht
glauben dass kapital und besetzten die
situation am 20 januar zu bestätigen
das war eine schreckliche situation die
wir durchmachen mussten um dann
schließlich die punkt zu erreichen und
scheinen nicht alle in ihrer partei das
genau so zu empfinden und auch so
schrecklich zu finden es ist erstaunlich
dass mehr als die hälfte der
republikaner im repräsentantenhaus
gestern dann trotzdem auch nach diesem
jahr doch auch dramatischen ereignissen
immer noch trump folgte und versuchte
die bestätigung von joe biden als
wahlsieger und als neuen präsident zu
verhindern wie erklären sie sich das
diese partei bestätigt
um uns dann wieder nach vorne zu richten
um in zukunft wieder eine partei zu sein
einen solch großen einfluss in dieser
partei hat die republikanische partei
und wir müssen uns unter diesem
präsidenten geschehen ist bleiben indem
wir den menschen das recht geben zu
reden wir werden sie an ihrer spitze
haben wollen
weil die demokratie in amerika sondern
in anderen demokratien weltweit in
gewissen schritte unternehmen um
sicherzustellen dass jeder das recht hat
ein anführer frei vom volk wählen zu
lassen sagt der frühere nationale
geheimdienst koordinator von donald
trump dan coats das gespräch ich hab
euch über die gelegenheit gefreut mit
ihnen zu sprechen
das interview mit deinem codes haben wir
aufgezeichnet und von meiner seite noch
eine korrektur dan coats verließ die
regierung trump nicht erst im letzten
sommer sondern schon 2009 10 nach
massiven sicherheitspolitischen
differenzen mit donald trump in berlin
äußerten sich heute auch bundeskanzlerin
und bundespräsident mit blick auf donald
trump nahmen beide dabei kein blatt vor
den mund
diese szenen die wir gesehen haben die
sind das ergebnis von lügen und noch
mehr lügen von spalt 3 und demokratie
verachtung von hass und hetze auch von
allerhöchster stelle
das ist eine historische zäsur für die
vereinigten staaten und das ist ein
angriff auf die liberale demokratie
überhaupt mich haben diese bilder wütend
und auch traurig gemacht zweifel am
wahlausgang wurden geschürt und das hat
die atmosphäre dafür bereitet dass die
ereignisse der nacht erst möglich
gemacht hat ähnlich bestürzt äußerte
sich auch emanuel makro und andere
europäische staats und regierungschefs
aber es gibt in europa sowohl den
parteien als auch in regierungen ja auch
blühende trumpets die auch sich selbst
und ihre rechtspopulistischen bewegungen
mit seinem wahlsieg 2016 im aufschwung
sei insofern ist es aufschlussreich sich
anzusehen wie aus diesem lager auf die
ereignisse gestern reagiert wird ein
überblick dazu quer durch europa
beginnend in deutschland
beatrix von storch gehört zu den größten
deutschen fans von donald trump deshalb
möchte die vize ard-vorsitzender heute
auch nicht über dessen verantwortung
reden sondern antwortet auf jede frage
mit demselben satz
der angriff auf das kapital das war ein
anschlag auf den rechtsstaat und der
rechtsstaat und die demokratischen
institutionen sind unantastbar
deswegen ist das was dort gestern
passiert ist auf der schachtel fordern
von den partei und fraktionschefs nur
eine schriftliche erklärung in der man
die ereignisse von washington aufs
schärfste verurteilt afg
bundestagsabgeordnete erkennen bis heute
joe biden 2 sieg nicht an eine partei
verliert ihr idol in italien hat sich
der chef der rechtspopulistischen lega
salvini stets als leidenschaftlicher
trump und präsentiert auch kurz vor der
us wahl
ich habe nicht die hoffnung verloren
dass er gewinnt heute nun verurteilte im
internet die vorgänge in washington so
gewalt ist nie eine lösung nie und
demonstriert später in einer
fernsehsendung per telefon noch mehr
distanz es ist kein geheimnis dass ich
die ideen der republikaner und von trump
unterstützt habe aber eine wahl ist eine
sache es ist was anderes bewaffnet das
parlament zu stürmen und sich
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei zu
liefern
bei besuchen in washington gegen polens
präsident duda stets an die lippen
trumps stolz wenn er im weißen haus
empfangen
seit jahren werben polenz
nationalkonservative regierung und du da
für eine dauerhafte us militärbasis fort
trump der arbeitstitel joe biden dagegen
hatte polens nationalkonservative
regierung verschnupft und mehr
rechtsstaatlichkeit angemahnt
präsident duda gratulierte beiden als
einer der letzten zum wahlsieg und zum
sturm aufs kapital lediglich ein tweet
das ganze sei eine innere angelegenheit
der vereinigten staaten
frankreichs nationalist nur marine le
pen standen von beginn an an der seite
von trams ideologen und deren chef der
wahlsieg donald trumps ist eine gute
nachricht für unser land
doch nach der jüngsten wahl gratulierte
sie dem gewinner nicht begründung das
spiel ist noch nicht vorbei schon
funktioniert ja termin erst nach dem
angriff auf das kapitol klingt das
anders es ist kein problem für mich oder
wen auch immer zu zu geben dass herr
beiden präsident ist präsident will das
aus den niederlanden seien donald trump
den vorboten einer großen rechten welle
auch in europa natürlich glaube ich dass
uns das enormen schub gibt und den
leuten zeigt hey es ist möglich im
bündnis mit europas ultrarechten
versuchte will dass das fahrwasser
donald trumps zu nutzen
doch kurz vor den niederländischen
wahlen will er die geister los werden
die auch er rief schockierend sein die
bilder aus washington das wahlergebnis
müsse respektiert werden
das ende des us präsidenten ist auch das
kleinlaute ende eines vorbild für die
rechten europas der sturm aufs kapital
und die damit ausgelösten weltweiten
erschütterungen dazu jetzt ein kommentar
von chefredakteur des zdf peter frey
nein amerikas demokratie ist noch nicht
gerettet der gescheiterte angriffe auf
das kapitol zeigt die gefährdet die usa
immer noch sind es gibt dafür drei
gründe die stolze republikanische partei
konnte und wollte ihren skrupellosen
präsidenten nicht stoppen
im gegenteil viel zu lange hat sie
opportunistisch auf ihn gesetzt
ein präsident der seine anhänger zum
sturm aufs parlament aufruft begeht
faktisch hochverrat
das muss bestraft werden solange seine
partei nicht mit trump mit seinen
radikalisierten anhängern und den
führenden gesichter dieser
gespenstischen vier jahre bricht bleibt
amerikas demokratie an kraft war
zweitens trump konnte nur dank seines
parallel universums in den digitalen
medien groß werden dass twitter und
facebook sich nun in allerletzter minute
von diesem
ihren follower könig im weißen haus
distanzieren ist pure heuchelei
wer die schrillsten formulierungen der
algorithmus belohnt wer alternative
fakten verbreitet den kompromiss
verteufelt der spaltet statt die
gesellschaft zusammenzuführen
drittens es geht nicht nur um trump es
geht auch um seine wähler auch die
verlierer der globalisierung oft sind es
wirtschaftlich gefährdete weiße einst
stolze vertreter der
mehrheitsgesellschaft müssen mitgenommen
werden
joe biden steht jetzt vor einer
schwierigen aufgabe ein politikangebot
für ganz amerika zu machen dass er die
mehrheit in beiden häusern hat
erleichtert ihm das politische geschäft
zur versöhnung amerikas wird das noch
nicht ausreichend aus dem sturm aufs
kapital sollten wir vor allem eins
lernen entschlossen gegen politische
extreme kämpfen auch wenn sie schon in
ämtern und in parlamenten sind die
demokratie kann auch von innen zerstört
werden das haben wir deutsche 1933
selbst erlebt das aber auch in den
vereinigten staaten ein präsident sein
land an den abgrund führen konnte macht
aus geschichte bittere warnende
gegenwart wieder frei kommentierte die
vorgängen den usa beherrschen natürlich
die weltnachrichten aber auch heute gab
es noch andere ereignisse 1 zweiter tag
der traditionellen winterklausur der
csu-landesgruppe im bundestag zu gast
war heute bundeskanzlerin merkel merkel
die online zugeschaltet war und
csu-landesgruppenchef dobrindt betonte
die gemeinsamkeit der beiden unions
parteien
merkel beschrieb das verhältnis als
lebendiges buch mit verschiedenen
kapiteln in dem man seit geraumer zeit
ein kapitel der gemeinsamkeit gestaltet
die landesgruppe hatte hier treffen zu
beginn dieses wahljahres neben der
korona pandemie vom oberbayerischen
klostersee und nach berlin verlegt
mecklenburg vorpommern will mit einer
landeseigenen stiftung die umstrittene
ostsee-pipeline nord stream zwei vor dem
aus bewahren
das hat der landtag in schwerin
beschlossen mit der stiftung sollen
drohende sanktionen der usa gegen am bau
beteiligte unternehmen umgangen werden
demnach sollen baumaterialien selbst
eingekauft und den firmen zum weiterbau
zur verfügung gestellt werden
nord stream 2 soll jährlich 55
milliarden kubikmeter gas von russland
nach deutschland liefern
in mehreren bundesländern sind ermittler
gegen ein internationales netzwerk
vorgegangen dass militante islamisten in
syrien mit geld unterstützt haben soll
wie die bundesanwaltschaft mitteilte
wurden drei personen vorläufig
festgenommen
inzwischen wurde untersuchungshaft
angeordnet das geld war den angaben
zufolge für eine terror gruppierung
vorgesehen die al kaida nahesteht und in
syrien einen sogenannten gottesstaat
errichten will
nordkorea will trotz internationaler
sanktionen sein militär weiter ausbauen
dadurch solle die sicherheit des landes
und der menschen gewährleistet werden
wie machthaber kim jong-un am zweiten
tag des parteikongresses sagte ob davon
auch die atomwaffen betroffen sind blieb
unklar
das autoritäre regime ist wegen seines
atomwaffenprogramms international
weitgehend isoliert und ungerührt von
allem was auf der welt geschieht
verbreitet sich derweil das corona virus
kräftig weiter auch in deutschland die
wichtigsten aktuellen meldungen dazu hat
christian kirsch zusammengestellt für
unseren corona ticker
das robert koch institut meldet heute 26
1391 corona neuinfektionen binnen eines
tages 1000 70 menschen starben an oder
mit dem virus allerdings bleibt eine
interpretation der daten schwierig da
laut lka um weihnachten und neujahr neue
fälle nur verzögert übermittelt wurden
klarheit über das aktuelle
infektionsgeschehen gibt es laut
regierung erst am 17 januar also in zehn
tagen die zahl der ans robert koch
institut gemeldeten impfungen gegen
kuwait 19 in deutschland ist im
vergleich zum vortag um mehr als 46.000
gestiegen seit dem beginn der
impfkampagne ende dezember ist das
mittel damit nun mindestens 400 17 1060
menschen gespritzt worden diese
gesamtzahl ergibt sich aus bisherigen
meldungen der bundesländer
die beiden unternehmen koubek und bayern
wollen gemeinsam bei der entwicklung
eines corona impfstoffs vorankommen wie
sie heute mit halten schlossen sie dazu
einen kooperationsvertrag das tübinger
biotech-unternehmen chor weg hatte im
dezember grünes licht für den start der
phase 3 studie für seinen m rna
impfstoff erhalten
china erlebt den größten ausbruch des
corona virus seit monaten in der provinz
hebei nahe der hauptstadt peking ist die
zahl der korona fälle in fünf tagen auf
mehr als 230 gestiegen
besonders betroffen ist die provinz
hauptstadt china shuangji heute
abgeriegelt wurde
die elf millionen einwohner dürfen die
metropole nicht mehr verlassen
die verschärfung des shutdowns in
deutschland bayer eigentlich dafür
gedacht mit möglichste regen kontakt
beschränkungen die zahlen wieder runter
zu bekommen möglichst schnell und
möglichst nachhaltig um aus dieser
endlos kette halber lockt downs
herauszukommen und aus sorge vor den
neuen virus mutationen
soweit der plan den vor zwei tagen auch
der regierende bürgermeister berlins als
vorsitzender der ministerpräsidenten
runde hier im heute-journal erläutert
unter anderem sagte michael müller das
zitat kein ministerpräsident im moment
das abenteuer eingehen wolle
die schulen zu früh wieder zu öffnen
mindestens bis ende januar so stand
dessen gemeinsamen beschluss sollten die
schulen zu bleiben das hört ein schüler
eltern und lehrer im lande und nahmen
diese ansage vermutlich auch ernst doch
keine 24 stunden später hatten diverse
bundesländer schon wieder andere
vorstellungen
allen voran berlin romanesco war und
henriette de maizière berichten
stille schulflure verwaiste klassenräume
lehre pausenhöfe der lockdown liegt in
berlin auch den unterricht in den
schulen nahm
doch das soll sich ab der kommenden
woche ändern präsenzunterricht mit
wechselnden gruppen zunächst für die
abschluss relevanten jahrgänge darüber
wurde heute im berliner abgeordnetenhaus
heftig debattiert ich möchte so dringend
wie möglich in den präsenzunterricht
weil ich weiß wie die sozialen folgen
sind wenn die kinder nicht in die schule
gehen aber in der abwägung was ich
ansonsten alles an maßnahmen beschließe
kann ich nicht wegdiskutieren dass es
auch infektionsketten gibt aus dem
schulgeschehen heraus für ein interview
stand der regierende bürgermeister heute
nicht zur verfügung stattdessen
verteidigt seine bildungssenatorin die
schule öffnungen wir haben den
gesundheitsschutz und auf der anderen
seite natürlich auch das recht auf
bildung im blick und was wir natürlich
auch tun dass wir immer wieder die
infektions lage im blick haben und immer
wieder neu entscheiden bundesweit
unterschiedliche pläne zur schule
öffnung in bayern beispielsweise bleiben
die schulen bis ende januar geschlossen
in brandenburg dagegen gibt es
präsenzunterricht diese woche für
abschluss relevante jahrgänge weitere
regelungen werden morgen entschieden
baden württemberg möchte wenn es das
infektionsgeschehen erlaubt zunächst die
grundschulen öffnen
unterschiedliche meinungen in den
ländern und auch bei den eltern in
berlin ging ein riss quer durch wir
haben die eltern die wie gesagt aufgrund
ihrer persönlichen erfahrungen und der
erfahrung mit der schule wie sie mit dem
schulisch angeleiteten lernen zuhause
umgeht
eltern die sagen ja meine mein kind
kannte bleiben dort wo es nicht gut
funktioniert dort haben wir natürlich
auch die eltern die sagen mein kind muss
zurück zusätzlich natürlich auch noch
zur beruflichen belastung zu der frage
stellung wenn ich zu lange zu hause
bleibe bekomme ich da nicht stress mit
meinem arbeitgeber besonders engagiert
momentan jene die gegen die
schuleröffnung sind eine online-petition
sammelte seit gestern bereits über
11.000 unterschriften
das ist natürlich ein krasser
widerspruch wenn wir auf der einen seite
im privaten
verpflichtet werden höchstens noch mit
einer person als familie uns zu treffen
und auf der anderen seite gehen aber die
kinder zur schule treffen sich dort mit
ihren klassenkameraden und
klassenkameraden sind natürlich
unterwegs in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und treffen sich auch
mit anderen kindern auf dem pausenhof
also das ist das gegenteil von kontakt
beschränkungen die schulen als
infektionsherd auch wenn kinder und
jugendliche oftmals nicht schwer
erkrankten schon öffnungen brauchen
konkrete inzidenz vorgaben fordern
virologen ich denke wir sollten alle
infektionsquellen und da gehören die
schulen noch mal dazu einfach vermeiden
verhindern die schulen zu lassen bis wir
unter dem incidents wert von mindestens
50 sind das recht auf bildung und der
schutz der gesundheit die schuleröffnung
ein schwieriger abwägungsprozess und
jetzt nochmals zunächst mit dem blick
auf die börse ja der hat der dax zum
ersten mal zeitweise die marke von
14.000 punkten übersprungen
auch für die digitale währung bitcoin
wird ein rekordwert vermeldet weil er
die halle was hat es mit dem mit coin
und dem massiven kursanstieg auf sich
also das hat ganz verschiedene gründe
einer ist sicher das interesse an
bitcoins einfach enorm gestiegen
dieses jahr sind reihenweise große
institutionelle investoren
versicherungen und unternehmen
eingestiegen
ja und dann nahm der online bezahldienst
paypal
die währung bitcoin in den usa als
zahlungsmittel auf und das war der
ritterschlag kurskapriolen sind bei
bitcoin keine seltenheit aber 2020 war
ein denkwürdiges jahr mit rund 7000
dollar gestartet fällt die währung im
frühjahr durch corona auf 4900 dollar
heute knackt sie die 40.000 dollar marke
bitcoin haftet aber seit jeher ein
zweifelhafter ruf an
kritiker bezeichnen sie als gangster
währung weil die überweisungen in
bitcoin und anderen crypto währungen
anonym sind können sie leicht für
kriminelle zwecke missbraucht werden
die frage jedoch ist ob bitcoin
nachhaltig vom aktuellen hype profitiert
als zahlungsmittel eignet sich die
digital währung kaum weil dafür ein
die kursschwankungen zu hoch sind
umstritten ist sie deswegen auch als
kapitalanlage
gut möglich außerdem dass crypto
währungen bald mächtige konkurrenz
bekommen
die ezb strebt eine eigene digitale
währung an ein grund mehr bei crypto
währungen vorsichtig zu sein
weitere halle vielen dank und bevor
gleich der wetterbericht zu den
aussichten bei uns folgt kurz ein
ungewöhnlich winterlicher blick nach
spanien
ein sturmtief sorgte in der provinz leon
im norden des landes für eine rekord
kälte von minus 35,8 grad auch in madrid
schneite es mehrere stunden lang für
morgen wurde für die hauptstadt die
höchste alarmstufe ausgerufen
das sturmtief soll mancherorts noch bis
anfang nächster woche anhalten
in madrid sollen die temperaturen nachts
auf bis zu minus zwölf grad sinken
das war von uns weitergeht vielleicht
bei markus lanz der mit seinen gästen
auf über die ereignisse in amerika
spricht und um 00 15 gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update mit anna zimmermann
und uns gibt es morgen wieder und zwar
nicht erst um 22 45 in den
programmzeitschriften noch ausgewiesen
sondern bereits um 22 uhr und die doku
balkans teil wird dann nach dem heutigen
eingesendet ist dann also doch wieder
sehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren dieses tief hier
kam aus osteuropa und es zieht bis
morgen abend auch richtung südosten
zurück
es nimmt dabei auch seine schneewolken
nicht vielleicht haben sie ja auch schon
ein bisschen schnee abbekommen aktuell
liegen ja in norddeutschland hier und da
durchaus 15 cm schnee und wenn es bei
ihnen vor der haustür noch grün ist bis
sonntag haben sie eine gewisse chance
dass es doch immerhin für so einen
leichten kleinen weißen haus reicht denn
die temperaturen bleiben einfach niedrig
heute nacht fällt auf jeden fall noch
eine menge schnee hier in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen da wird es dann auch
gefährlich glatt auf den straßen auch in
norddeutschland gibt es noch schnee
regen schauer an den alpen ist es
dagegen klar und dann sinken die
temperaturen über den schnee flächen bis
minus 11 grad sonst liegen die
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus zwei
und minus sechs grad und morgen liegen
die temperaturen zwischen -3 grad an den
alpen und 4 grad am niederrhein oder
auch auf den ostfriesischen inseln und
die schneewolken ziehen sich immer
weiter richtung südosten zurück
auch an der ostseeküste kann es morgen
noch einige schneeregenschauer geben und
chancen auf sonne haben sie zum beispiel
schleswig holstein besser aber klappt
das mit der sonne am oberrhein oder auch
am alpenrand
am samstag hat das im erzgebirge noch
mal leicht flocken und es bleibt in
jedem fall winterlich die temperaturen
pendeln wie schon in den vergangenen
tagen immer um den gefrierpunkt schönen
abend noch